the airstrike occurred in the nangarhar  province of afghanistan  i can confirm as more information has  come in  that two high-profile isis targets  were killed  and one was wounded  and we know of zero civilian casualties  without specifying any future plans  i will say that we will continue to have  the ability to defend ourselves  and to leverage over the horizon  capability to conduct counter terrorism  operations as needed  we continue to evacuate american  citizens and vulnerable afghans out of  kabul  in fact there are approximately 1  400 individuals at the kabul airport who  have been screened and manifested for  flights today  as i said yesterday we have the ability  to include evacuees on military airlift  out of afghanistan until the very end  this is a massive military diplomatic  security and humanitarian undertaking  for the united states  and our allies